ragazzuoli una volta ogni tanto esce un
horror vero c'è un horror della madonna
te la spiego ragazzi questa è una demo
chiusa tra l'altro quindi grazie a dio
sono uscito entrarci così almeno mi
prendo i jump square per voi come sono
felice il gioco in questione si chiama
the beast inside un po come quando
prendi voti brutti a scuola credo che
non sia family friendly ma non ne sono
sicurissimo
salve ma sono io che faccio del male
alle persone neri contrario va bene
quindi sono una brava persona
una settimana prima ok anche fatto
vedere come va a finire ho capito
[Musica]
c'è una volta un uomo a eccola la tizia
di prima sì però io non ho capito una
roba ma io sono il tipo che le stava
facendo le cose brutte
ah sì sono io ad un perfetto quindi io
sono impazzito primo la bestia dentro
siamo
oh che bello
siamo in questa casa in mezzo alla
foresta è bellissima giuro però di
giorno di notte non credo lo sia quindi
2 agosto del 1979 apro la porta il suo
morendo di caldo appena letta la parola
agosto allora cosa devo fare qua ma io
fatemi capire quindi io sono il cattivo
ha usato il corso per tirarlo gioco bene
io quindi sono il cattivo del gioco che
è ma quando andata la mia moglie
esattamente mezzo alla foresta
io posso andare a controllare nella
foresta se c'è qualcuno qualcosa messo
alla madonna dei dinosauri va dai
ragazzi portiamo le casse dentro perché
mi sembra giusto che avevano che lavora
la dhl ed ho portato dentro le cose
queste cose si fanno per la patata solo
per questo amico mia se no non ci
sarebbe motivo
grazie arrivederci dove è la zia andate
lì sopra premesso che bella sta a casa
se fosse meno tetro sarebbe ancora
meglio prove non sono studiato che
cos'era dining room sarebbe la dove fa
il pranzo sala pranzo che avrà vado in
macchina lurida [ __ ] che dimentica
le chiari chiavi le chiavi della
soffitta perché mai dovrebbero essere in
macchina tra l'altro sul retro l'ho
trovata come ma che schifo ma buttatele
le robe è arrivato amazon questo gioco
corriere simulator farmi capire che
bello me la immaginavo un po più allegra
c'è la soffitta della soffitta number
one piede di porco
prendiamolo che serve sempre negli
horror anche se sono io cattivo quindi
non dovrei dare da solo in testa e la
questa l'ho già vista è questa loggia vi
tesoro ora che bella che c'è qua è tanto
la teniamo l'inps c'è una porta a madama
un attico e più grosso di casa mia c'è
manco possibile ragazzi dire che
possiamo scendere tesoro trovato un
ascia ci interessa tesoro ma dov'è mia
moglie è andata a finire
l'amore tesoro della mia vita ai raid
allora portiamo sta roba
dove deve stare quindi sugli scatoloni
c'è la tegola bella state gola cioè la
stanza è bella in ordine ci manca solo
le tegole che escono dal pavimento fare
non stradica questa qua sotto i sordi ci
stanno i soldi lo so io apprendiste
banconote si sta roba qua lo posso
vendere e vabbè dentro le scarpe
va bene cosa faccio togliti un attimo
per cortesia che serve niente betis cosa
vuol dire ma cosa ne posso sapere io
cosa devo scrivere non è che ci sono
degli indizi da trovare in casa ma non
lo so non sono capace io devo trovare
sicuramente c'è scritto da qualche parte
sarà un nome sicuramente però non
capisco quale probabilmente non è a caso
fra vj non ci sono peccato non ci sono
lettere fede inglese how the number one
aeroportino per scrivere fa vj per of
faith ok favi fei nicolas cage e belle
figure che cosa sbloccherà sbloccherà
nicolas cage non lo sappiamo
c'è un quaderno che spero non sia il def
non siamo nella cacca
non me lo fa leggevo le da di sensore
adesso leggo quel quaderno di vento
satana e vado a cercare tutti quelli che
mettono dislike ai video presenti che
tutto il giorno a scrivere a minchia
sono stati dietro nel tempo devo cercare
delle candele eccola qua
questa non è la lanterna tipo guardia
amnesia chapter ii è hold lantern prendi
prendi questa sì che è un atmosfera da
horror 27 settembre nel 1864 e la
madonna non potevi caricare i video con
la fibra mi chiama anche tu cerchi prog
e quadri ok madonna che ambientazione
horror incredibile cosa ci fa una serie
in mezzo alle palle togliti del buon
vino portati la bottiglia di vino che
nel caso la offre i mostri signori uno
chardonnay il 65 si vabbè ma mica ma
tieni in ordine santo gesù posso
accendere le candele abel sarebbe anche
utile visto che notte e mi sto calando
leggermente addosso però va bene ma ce
n'è una sola andiamo a risparmio
ovviamente sono un gran figo ecco queste
erano le foto profilo di facebook nel
1800 niente se ce ne do tutto profitti
fiammiferi mi serviva eccoli qua o
sorella morta marazza grava che kakà ha
permesso questa è casa mia ha permesso
una sega va beh salve mi sono cagà era
la fine si è aperta la sola giustamente
la finestra va benissimo
privo di kew di cure i nomi spunta il
bambino morto lo sapevano era un uccello
prof
salve no non vogliamo corrieri amazon in
questo momento grazie ho pensato già io
a mettere i pacchi madonna che brutto
vabbè io se vedo un tizio così mi do
fuoco però senta lei non è non stia nel
mio giardino che chiama la polizia che
qua guardi che un casino so che ha
attirato dalla mia foto profilo ammesso
like era accesa prima questa è certo è
che storia story toy story finis quindi
permesso che cos'è questo penso a casa
tua zio sono sei sceso così era stato ma
c'è un tizio l'ho visto mi prendete per
il culo gioco non mi prendere per i
fondelli devi tornare a casa e sicuro
vivaci sono delle pentole belle questa
non è una roba che ho visto all'inizio
nella intro non posso becco le cesoie
premi e prendere tutto il resto non
prenderlo per l'amor di dio non si sa
mai che tutti debba difendere proprio le
prendi le let's go vabbè semi di no no
no no no no
no no no no no no ti ammazzo vi uccido
la famiglia ragazzi no io ho scaricato
questa demo perché voglio divertirmi non
per fare ste cagate prove senta lei non
si fissano le foto degli altri lo sa e
non si indossano questi pigiami
bruttissimi ecco perfetto faccia tutto
quello che vuole io vado in cucina le
preparo qualcun the day belle cose devo
mica toccarlo veda jolo cos'è successo
domanda non l'ho visto perché non ce la
facevo il mio coraggio non arriva fino a
questo punto extra toni si è riattivata
la lanterna che sia spenta ovviamente
perché li fanno così bene giorno nel
2018 non potranno farli male
oh mio dio ma loro non ci vivrei mi ha
neanche sotto tortura in una casa così
ma che brutto tempo d'ordine mamma mia
va beh signori mi piace un sacco giocare
agli horror è per questo che ho fatto
l'ho youtuber come mestiere proprio mi
viene da dentro come i peti ecco e a
proposito di mannaia
dov'è che è finito il tizio e gliela
offro volentieri e va beh ma allora me
le tirate proprio poi c'è una scala per
cortesia togli la game porta già sfiga
blocca la porta blocca tutta la pa
hockey deve entrare qua ma non è mia
corridoio questo scusa e si è così
chi bussa prego è avanti ti do una mano
io aspetto aspetta aspetta che magari
non riesce la fine mi dai la mano a
pulire per cortesia a marcelo le cesoie
posso aprire ma non è che ci abbia tutta
sta voglia riaprirla è però vabbè
chiudetevi gli occhietti ni
[Musica]
odio la mia vita sì c'era qualcosa
cos'è chi è un'altra porta no no no
vabbè se da ciao ciao mi dissi vabbeh
vada mi prese per il culo
devo andare proprio di ninfee va bene e
va bene ovvio che divide succeda c'è
pure io non lo so però se hai voglia di
continuare a scendere nell'inferno io
sono contento qui non c'è audio insomma
non c'e audio non c'è non si sente
niente negli horror quando non si sente
niente vorrei morire
finché ti piace però il suo quadro è
fango lo zucchero al mio tempo nel mio
campanello il mio campanello chi è chi è
che deve portare a passarmi trequarti
adesso faccio vedere chi era mi era
pietro che arriva nei momenti giusti
posso uscire ha pure non posso marco
torna indietro ho bisogno di un lock pic
che sarebbe il grimaldello riscoprire la
sua porta che dove non c'era primo brava
bena scusami ma c'era e non lo so small
pocket ho tratto una tasca come faccio
io cos'è sta roba scusa non puoi
guardare dentro la tasca e poi eccolo
qua grimaldello ah beh allora a posto
hai visto
posso uscire di qua maledizione ecco
come sky
amen hai visto che scassinatore proverbi
il lupin senta lei da ore che mi fissa i
quadri e le altre cose se ne vada per
favore
nasce la chiave chiave misteriosa d'arco
demonio devi morire e devi morire
tu non hai senso di esistere nella mia
vita mi hai fatto proprio scorretto e
non è neanche in casa mia mi ha suonato
il campanello previsti 600 ragazzi cosa
se vi è piaciuta molto mi piace questo
giochino nell'archiviare sono stati
precisi non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]